à tout juste neuf ans moyo est la
nouvelle star du zoo de thoiry une
arrivée grandement attendu car le zoo
n'avait pas accueilli d'éléphants depuis
plus de vingt ans son transfert il y a
quelques jours depuis l'allemagne a été
particulièrement encadrée et supervisé
donc la caisse arrivée au parc allemand
l'animal est entraîné à rentrer dans
laquelle on fait rentrer on doit manger
ont l'habitude pour qu'il rende qui
sorte qu'on l'enferment dans la caisse
on le relâche c'est comme ça tu ici tout
fait il est chargé dans sa caisse il est
mis dans un camion et ils arrivent ici
où il est déchargé donc dans la maison
donc seraient ses serres c'est un
transport un peu long un peu fastidieux
c'est long à organiser mais globalement
c'est un transport pas plus dit pas
différent par rapport à d'autres espèces
moyo partage désormais l'espace de
l'autre pachydermes de thoiry ben âgé de
42 ans ils se sont rapidement acclimaté
l'un à l'autre grâce aux exercices mis
en place par les soigneurs quand on
accueille un animal sauvage dans un parc
zoologique on va mettre en place tout un
protocole de mise en contact donc là en
l'occurrence c'était avec ben l'éléphant
adultes qui étaient déjà sur site donc
on va d'abord les faire se rencontrer à
travers des grilles de protection ils
vont se sentir se jauger un petit peu et
puis rapidement on va quand même le
mettre dans l'enclos avec avec ben parce
que on essaye de ne pas faire monter
trop la pression c'est vrai quand on
attend trop longtemps il ya une pression
qui peut monter donc on va le mettre
rapidement dans l'enclos et là ça c'est
hyper bien passé ben a été très
accueillants avec moyo donc donc
franchement c'était au top l'arrivée de
mme hoyos s'inscrit dans le cadre du
projet terre d'afrique développé par le
zoo de thoiry qui se veut à la fois
immersif et pédagogique
le projet prévoit la construction d'une
nouvelle maison de 1400 m² pour les
éléphants des loges immersif pour
accueillir les visiteurs une volonté
également rendre les déplacements au
sein de la réserve plus écologique il y
aura plusieurs ma façon de visiter la
réserve le véhicule thermique lui va
être amenée à disparaître au fur et à
mesure des années pour qu'on 2028 ce
soit complètement disparu sur touahri
les véhicules électriques vont
certainement arriver aussi de manière
assez ludique mais un véhicule que vous
ne connaissez pas et qu'on est en train
de vous préparer et puis on va voir
aussi nos camions bruce se transformer
en véhicules propres et puis tout ce qui
est véhiculé commun qui va nous
permettre de continuer à avoir aussi les
groupes et plusieurs trajets plusieurs
aventures vont naître dans la réserve
puisque la réserve a entièrement bouger
un peu comme un benneteau ou les espèces
vont se sont retrouvés se reconnecter 1
pour pouvoir justement est de plus en
plus en en mêlant géant simplement
immersion les travaux du projet terre
d'afrique s'étendront sur 3 ha et
débuteront en octobre 2022 en attendant
d'ici quelques semaines un troisième
éléphant fera son entrée au zoo il
s'agit de yabous un éléphanteau venus de
suède